hey guys welcome and I'm here with a
fantastic man and a special guest who
goes by the name of Gabriel or Gabriel
Gabriel
so we're here in Lisbon capital of
Portugal and um you know he happened to
be here as well so we decided to make an
interview and I think it's going to be a
great one hopefully so first and
foremost uh who are you what is your
language background what is your
background in general so is born in
Brazil was born and raised in Brazil and
I started learning English at the age of
10. and I finished an entire course a
six-year course uh basically in Brazil
we pay a lot of money for those so my my
Dad paid for it and then I moved to
Canada when I was 17. well get it when I
when I got uh to Canada it was a bit
interesting because comparably you know
uh
compared to other Brazilians my English
was very good however at an absolute
standpoint it was terrible like it was
just but like I struggle to understand
people I struggle to communicate often
people would be just like oh like uh
what'd you say can you repeat it so
I always thought it wasn't gifted at
languages that I started learning German
and French at the same time in my early
20s and I got to B2 in four years in
both of them so I kind of developed this
uh method to do to learn two languages
at once
and um excited with with the success
that I had with that I went for other
languages then I started learning
Italian and Dutch at the same time
and uh then Russian and Mandarin and
they just kept going and uh you got
bitten by the polyglot bug yes so you
you learn languages like in pairs like
every time you learned normally yeah two
languages at once okay interesting thank
you for the introduction no problem good
so now I have a list of questions I
printed that in advance because I knew
we would meet well prepared so
um I'm good she's gonna go through some
of them uh let's start with the first
one and that is what's the nicest or
most memorable compliment you've gotten
when speaking a foreign language so
basically uh I I would say that it's a
reaction that I often get when I speak
Russian is a very positive one and so
like often Russians will be just like oh
you have shock it like I'm I'm in shock
because you're Russian so good it's not
that amazing but like it's good enough
to impress uh I still have long ways to
go to just truly Master the language but
I like to recite uh Pushkin it was my
favorite poet
so normally that tends to really
um impress the Russian people so like uh
yeah that's one of the things that I
really like the year as well normally in
Mandarin to uh people but like sometimes
Chinese people will be like oh how long
did you live in China and I haven't been
to China so that's a big compliment too
which I think is pretty pretty cool of
course okay so let's talk about this
this was the compliment stuff you know
let's talk about like that one yes okay
this one what has been the most awkward
situation you've been involved in you've
been involved in when speaking of
foreign language so recently this is a
recent story I'm trying to make it short
because it's just kind of funny I was a
and my favorite uh Cemetery in Paris
Palace it's kind of weird but it spends
a lot of time in fellowships I don't
know why but it's it's a it's got a
beautiful Ambiance to just go like walk
around you know it's very calm anyway so
I was there too calm way too cold way
too bad they were very quiet
good pun
um so I was just walking
um
and then this elderly lady
just she seemed frazzled and uh she
asked me in German if I could help her
and it just to let you guys know
normally nobody approaches you in German
in Paris right right so then I told her
in German like yeah I'll be happy to
help how can I how can I help you then
she started trying to explain what was
happening that it that it didn't quite
get because she was really struggling
with German so she switched into Russian
that was like okay speak that too so
like then I started asking her a few
questions then she couldn't really
explain in Russian either
so uh she switched switched into polish
my Publisher's not that good maybe I
reach that like A2 and then she kept
saying something a vase chip which I
believe is exit and I was like oh she's
she's lost because it's a gigantic
cemetery and then explained in uh uh in
German and she was still very confused
though because her German was a bit
basic and I guess she just spoke those
languages maybe like A1 German A1
Russian and then it obviously flew in
Polish and then I told her in Polish
that I uh that I like uh that I like
Chopin that she went nuts because
Chopin's buried at Battleship she went
bananas she want bananas and she spoke a
very rapid polish that I understood
maybe 20 of and then I explained to her
like how to get out of the cemetery and
then 15 minutes later she was still lost
and she was asking this French gentleman
the same question in German I saw from
afar and the the gentleman was like um
and then basically I try to explain to
her again how to get out interesting
story and all this happening in Belize
yes one of the most beautiful iconic
places cemeteries in the world where
Oscars
genre favorite composers there's a lot
of yeah it's an exciting it's well
amazing maybe not exciting place but
it's a really interesting place really
interesting place it's true hey so let's
go back to the questions if you could
this is an interesting one if you could
start your language Journey all over
again what would you do differently
learn different languages learn them in
a different order or learn them in a
different way for that matter yeah I
think I would maybe keep the order
because I think that you know I I
started with English which is which was
obviously a really really important
language it is still a really important
language
um then I went you know Spanish I kind
of learned that through osmosis but like
in the in the meantime you know and of
course I still have long ways to go to
truly Master it fully but then French
and German but anyway like I think that
the most important
it goes back to what I what I uh was
saying when I was introducing myself is
that basically uh in the Brazilian
Language School what happened was that
um we focused way too much on grammar
and like a lot of like little written
exercises and you know the like very
traditional
um learning
methods and looking back like a lot of a
lot of things were like really for we
would focus on low frequency words not
enough uh exposure so definitely change
that it'll get a lot more exposure to
the language
um try to speak as much as possible try
to engage with the language in different
ways and not just rely on a course and
that's that's the main thing I would say
yeah I agree 100 but this thing that you
said in the Brazilian school system I
think it's worldwide is it yeah it's
true seven friends same in Canada same
in Italy probably everyone yeah that's
it okay well a great answer
rapidly various two seconds uh we have a
lot of other questions here we have so
many it would take us three hours we
have to decide some I had to skip one
page of questions we're gonna get to
that um in other videos which language
would you use to seduce someone
and why and why I would say oh first let
me preface this is we've been going
around we met in Porto as well this guy
knows how to talk to people thank you as
well
we had a great time
the you know Gabriel the Hollywood in
so uh I would say probably French or
Italian because I mean both they're
objectively
beautiful I would say and you know of
course like that when you ask someone
like oh what's your favorite like what
language do you think is the most
beautiful there's some element of
subjectivity but I think that it's
undeniable that the French and Italian
are just gorgeous languages and they're
just uh they can be very easy you know
yeah we've got I've had them on
taste
it just sounds
it's in my blood it's in my heart too
and the French too it's just like
elegant you know like as you just
you know maybe not the Quebec accent
even though you know I'm gonna eat him
as well but uh just kidding it's it's a
cute accent but I love hearing a lot of
quebecois here in in Portugal a lot of
friends and even a lot of kids
look at those okay so Italian and French
is that you used to seduce the ladies
that I would yes
so which language or languages have you
changed
the most about uh maybe about how one
sounds or how challenging it is but a
language that is giving you a new
perspective I would say definitely
Mandarin because I I when I started
learning I was really torn between
Japanese and Mandarin because back then
I was I was a lot more attracted to
Japanese culture and I just thought it
was a a nicer sounding language and
everything and but I chose Mandarin just
because it seemed more challenging and
it's more you know it's got a billion
speakers in the world so I thought may
as well learn Mandarin and but I didn't
like it as much initially but now I
really do and now I think it's a I like
the culture a lot more too it's just
such an interesting culture such a cool
language and I think it sounds uh nice
too like basically so this is an
interesting point that I myself for
example here we're in Portugal and
people the the kind of the version of
Portuguese that people speak here a lot
of people don't like it so a lot of
people keep asking me why did you learn
um Portuguese from Portugal Portuguese
and my answer is that well it's a like
it's a European version it's true that
you know Brazil has many many speakers
like actually over 200 million yeah so
if you compare them with the eight mil
the mirror 8 million speakers of
Portugal Portuguese from Portugal it's a
huge difference
but I have to tell the truth when I
listened to uh when I heard Portuguese
from Portugal around and I didn't speak
it and it sounded right like Russian
first and foremost true some Slavic
and then I didn't like the sound of it
but now I really do what else well I
think when you speak a language in
Italian
so when you start speaking the language
and you produce an articulate sounds in
your mouth you want to learn more right
we'll learn more and start liking it so
same for Mandarin I think Japanese
sounds like I don't know people who
don't for a person who doesn't speak
either Japanese or Mandarin they might
find maybe Japanese more enticing more
alluring but at the end of the day I
think when you start speaking language
you start liking it you know like when
you maybe you don't imagine that you are
dating a girl you don't know if you like
it that much but then you start talking
to her you start to get to know her
better and you start liking her more and
more so that's true
um anyway so so you know just go beyond
the superficial
um elements of
the language right exactly you go deep
you go deep into the language it's true
you go deeper okay so which language
you've changed your mind the most about
already asked you this question how do
you go about choosing your next language
to learn that is a a really cool
question normally I I like to
um follow my heart in a way so just like
oh like I'm really I follow up with some
element about language I don't know like
I just get really into I get really into
the
um the culture or the music and then I
just want to go and learn but it also
depends on uh I take how some logical
approach as well for instance because I
you know I'm somewhat comfortable with
Russian uh so I wanted to go further
with syllabic languages and I think that
the next one that I would really like to
learn is Polish so that's why I I'm
wondering yeah well well basically
there's I mean Polish people are awesome
they're just so nice
um basically
country in a great culture yeah like I
haven't been to Poland but I've met a
lot of cool Polish people in Vancouver
as well as in Paris where I live and um
the language sounds very cute I find
like I like the way it sounds and uh
basically I've already gotten to like
maybe A2 at best so I just I thought
well why not go further and um and
another language that I really want to
learn is Japanese because like I've I
really like the culture really like
Naruto I really like not just a little
bit you know like a lot of things about
the uh karate karate for
a little while so it's something that
has always like drawn me that attracted
me really makes no sense okay on to the
next question uh what is the next
language do you plan to learn okay we've
covered that how many languages have you
started but then stopped learning a lot
a lot of them because they went through
a phase
I'll say maybe like I don't know I'd say
even like 15 uh because like I went
through a phase that I was just picking
up uh Pimsleur audiobooks from the
Vancouver Library so then I just started
Tagalog
uh Arabic uh check uh polish but then it
just went a little bit further polish
um Catalan that I actually got decent at
like nine years ago but then it just
kind of
so I started learning so many different
languages uh Greek uh Hebrew those are
languages that I learned uh I just
learned the very Basics and then I
thought well unfortunately I don't have
enough time to learn all of them at once
as much as I would love to so then those
are languages that I want to come back
to
someday but I yep for now they're
they're on the on the The Waiting lines
there yes okay uh
as far as I'm concerned I think I
started learning Romanian and a couple
of other languages and then I stopped
but I think it's it's normal you know it
was more you explore yeah okay I like
this maybe you can always go back in
time you get in time now that'd be very
cool
DeLorean in it exactly you take into the
Lord to learn a language with a new
method now that you have this you know
experience go back
and tell yourself in the past like don't
do this like don't focus on grammar that
much cool that's
so uh one last question uh before we go
and the question goes like this if
languages had to remain a hobby and you
couldn't make a living off of them what
would you be doing right now as a
profession that's a very cool question I
think that maybe I would still be
tutoring math because that was my
business before I started really
tackling languages and so I had a
tutoring business and then that just
transitioned into the language business
that I have uh now and I have a presence
in 119 countries
uh over 59 000 students
and uh so I'm happy with that but like
of course like if I had
um to go back to teaching calculus why
not I I believe that I myself I really
like mathematics I think you have to
follow what your heart tells you it's
true he's an engineer yes impressive guy
at the end of the day I ended up doing
you ended up doing this I ended up
working with language learning and I'm
very happy that I did so I think so just
to conclude I think you should follow
what your heart says not the society not
your peers not your family not even your
family members I think you should follow
what you really stand for and then you
know and that's cheap library has
changed our lives that's true really
so a couple of other things couple of
observations uh before uh we we finish
um we have made multilingual video here
too in Portugal and I will put the link
in the description box we've talked in
eight languages I think something like
eight languages nine languages
um so if you want you can check it in
the link below I think it's a great
interview
um and uh the second thing is where can
people find you
so I got a my Instagram is Gabriel
polyglot or at Gabriel polyglot as well
as Gabriel polyglato So I have two
Instagrams uh or on YouTube Gabrielle
it's great so thank you for watching and
uh we will see you next and very soon
take a look and cheers bye bye ciao